vers un nouveau programme à d'appui à
financier entre le fmi et la tunisie en
vue d'une sortie de crise dans tout cas
l objectif des rencontres virtuelles qui
se tiennent jusqu'au 22 février entre
l'organisation internationale et tunis
ont fait le point avec notre
correspondant là-bas bassam chez bis la
tunisie à l'heure de la dernière chance
elle d'obtenir un accord avec le fonds
monétaire international seule solution
pour boucler son budget de 2022 est
sortie d'une crise financière sans
précédent une série de réunions
virtuelles sont prévus du 14 au 22
février entre une équipe des services du
fmi et les autorités tunisiennes
représenté par le ministre des finances
le directeur de la banque centrale ou
encore le ministre de l'économie et de
la planification objectif clarifier le
projet de réforme que la tunisie doit
engager pour convaincre son bailleur de
fonds en vue d'un nouveau programme de
financement un programme autour de
quatre axes principaux pour la paix de
2022 et 2024 et qui comprend la
restructuration de la fonction publique
la réforme du système de compensation la
gouvernance des entreprises publiques et
la réforme du système fiscal une
opération séduction délicate pour la
tunisie face à un bailleur de fonds bien
décidé à faire preuve de fermeté tunis
avait en novembre dernier solliciter le
fmi pour une nouvelle aide de 4
milliards de dol un peu de temps après
la formation du gouvernement ne d'âge la
bouden confronté à une instabilité
politique chronique et une crise
sanitaire qui a attisé les déséquilibres
déjà existants tels qu'une dette
extérieure de 30 milliards d'euros en
2021 et un déficit budgétaire de 6 7% du
pib le pays du jasmin qui n'a jamais
réussi à redresser ses finances depuis
la révolution de 2011 ne cesse de
s'enfoncer dans la crise sans être
capable de fournir aux familles des
garanties solides alors que l'union
européenne a annoncé étudier des
sanctions économiques contre l'état
tunisien suite à la décision de cailly
sayed de dissoudre le conseil supérieur
de la magistrature tunis ne semble plus
avoir d'autre choix que de s'aligner
rapidement sur les exigences du fmi pour
espérer sortir enfin la tête de l'eau et
assurer sa relance économique